for most of us January was a normal
month at school we learned together we
ate together we played together we do
not with each other everyday but as the
corona virus spread our world was
upended in February hundreds of millions
of us lost access to our schools by the
end of March
nearly every school on Earth was closed
closing schools creates distance between
us the distance was a virus it reduces
hospital visits it saves lives we're
proud to help flatten the curve but now
we need your help to keep the pandemic
from flattening your spirits here's how
you can help it's graduation season for
millions of students throughout the
world
we can't attend or support 2020
graduations in person but that doesn't
mean billions of us can't support
graduating classes of 2020 online we
need your help
graduates and supporters of graduates to
make this year a worldwide celebration
of the hopes the dreams the ideas and
the futures of an entire generation of
young people with support from Ted we've
outlined all the ways you can get
involved with this worldwide celebration
here we are the students whose lives
have been impacted by kovin 19 together
our ideas will define the world's future
visit ted.com slash graduation to sign
up I support our future today
[Music]
you